Друзі, всім привіт - настав час продовжити тему зі сміттям.
Сьогодні мені треба викинути старий одяг.
Зазвичай в Німеччині його викидають ось у такі контейнери для одягу і взуття.
Давайте поглянемо, що відбувається з викинутим одягом далі,
а також як збирають і  переробляють "зондермюль" - спеціальне сміття,
яке не можна викидати в контейнери біля будинку:
отруйні речовини, батарейки, електроприлади, метал та габаритні речі.
0 7-й ранку виїжджаю з бази комунальної компанії Бонн Оранж разом зі сміттярем Ронні.
У подорожньому листі на сьогодні - район Бонна Енденіх -  24 контейнери з одягом і взуттям,
які треба зібрати за 8 годин робочої зміни.
Ми спорожняємо наші контейнери раз на тиждень.
Зазвичай вони повні, як оцей.
Ронні працює без напарника. Він сам і водить вантажівку, і переносить одяг з контейнерів.
Здивувало те, що спорожнення контейнерів відбувається повністю вручну.
Відчувається свіжий запах пральних засобів.
Речі у Німеччині треба викидати випраними і запакованими.
Про це нагадує картинка-інструкція. Однак не всі її дотримуються.
Ось, наприклад, залишки килимового покриття.
Їх не має бути у контейнері для старого одягу.
Це сміття потребує окремого сортування. Для нас це - зайва робота.
Несподівано для мене тема збирання старого одягу набула кримінального характеру.
Легальний контейнер компанії Бонн Оранж з телефоном і повністю з усіма реквізитами.
А біля нього, тут трохи позаду - контейнери без будь-яких телефонів і без назви компанії.
Ось це два нелегальні контейнери.
Все працює, незважаючи на заіржавілий та занедбаний вигляд
і, судячи з глухого звуку, - він повний.
Не на камеру у компанії Бонн Оранж пояснили, що сміттярі і правоохоронці намагаються домовитися,
хто юридично відповідатиме за демонтаж нелегальних контейнерів.
А поки вони домовляються, ділки роками отримують тисячі тонн безкоштовного секонд-хенду,
який потім продають за кордоном, зокрема, й в Україні.
Ронні зібрав за зміну одну тонну вісімсот кілограмів одягу і взуття.
Уявляєте, які це обсяги?
За моїми спостереженнями, у Бонні приблизно однакова кількість легальних контейнерів
і контейнерів без розпізнавальних знаків. І це ще не все.
Друзі, а ось він - ще один приклад злочинності у сміттєвій сфері.
Подивіться, на цьому контейнері збитий замок.
Відкриваємо.
Дивіться - а всередині вже всі пакети розірвані і найкращі речі вже хтось відібрав вночі.
З 24-х контейнерів фірми Бонн Оранж - на 4-х були зламані замки.
На цей випадок у Ронні із собою набір нових замків.
Легально зібраний старий текстиль згодом потрапляє на заводи із сортування і переробки.
Чотириста тонн щодня приймає завод компанії SOEX під Лейпцигом.
Перший етап – відбір одягу, який ще можна носити.
Найефективніший метод переробки - дати одягу друге життя.
Речі з Німеччини, що у доброму стані, після сортування згодом легально продають
по цілому світу.
Або безкоштовно роздають благодійні німецькі організації.
Другий етап - подрібнення текстилю.
Машини рвуть тканину на крихітні шматочки, щоб у підсумку волокна різних виробів перемішалися.
Третій етап. Отриману сировину, яка нагадує різнокольорову бавовну, пресують
і виготовляють з неї шумоізоляціні панелі для автомобілів,
а також наповнювачі для автомобільних крісел.
Виготовити, наприклад, зі старої футболки нову - неможливо.
Як показує цей експеримент, нитка, отримана  з переробленої футболки, легко рветься,
і з неї неможливо зіткати нову міцну тканину.
Це можливо лише у пропорції 50 на 50 з новою бавовною.
Перед відправкою одягу далі на переробку Ронні заїжджає на станцію сортування
так званого спеціального сміття - німецькою "зондермюль".
Сміттяр мусить відсортувати тут зайві речі, які люди викинули у контейнер для текстилю.
Килимове покриття, як і переважна більшість сучасних килимІв, йде на спалювання,
бо містить синтетичні волокна, що не підлягають переробці.
Часто німці самі привозять на станцію прийому спецсміття свій "зондермюль".
Штефан приїхав на електровелосипеді.
Тут у мене все, що я не можу викинути в звичайний смітник:
метал, батарейки, старі електроприлади і таке інше.
На станції сортування стоять металеві контейнери,
які після наповнення легко кріпляться до вантажівок.
На кожному з них містяться таблички
Старе мастило, фарби, лаки, розчинники, електроприлади,
будівельне сміття, метал, дерево, садові відходи, речовини на спалення.
Сміттярі підходять до Штефана, щоб допомогти йому рознести відходи до різних контейнерів.
У Штефана все розфасовано.
Старі шурупи, цвяхи і металевий дріб'язок він привіз в окремій каструлі - це йде у метал.
Галогенну лампу – сюди, батарейки - сюди,
автомобільний акумулятор - сюди,
легкозаймисті токсичні лаки – в окремий протипожежний герметичний контейнер,
іграшкова машинка сина на дистанційному керуванні  - до   електроприладів.
Як довго ви все це збирали?
Півроку-рік, відколи переїхали на нове місце.
Настав час позбутися всього цього.
Що саме можна здавати на станції прийому спецсміття,
прописано в окремому розпорядженні про перелік відходів, сміттярі знають його на пам'ять.
Навіть сумлінний Штефан, попри зразкове сортування, врахував не всі тонкощі.
Сміттярі сказали везти пінопласт назад додому.
Це тут викидати не можна.
Мушу викинути це вдома у жовтий контейнер для упаковки або у чорний для сміття на спалювання.
Шкода, було б добре його теж позбутися.
Для тих, кому щось з викинутого приглЯнулося – спеціальне попередження.
Цікаво, що біля контейнеру з металом стоїть табличка – витягувати речі заборонено.
це для тих, хто захоче пошукати тут кольорові метали.
Міхаель Вольтер на вантажнику вивантажує чергову партію електроприладів.
Він працює сміттярем вже 34 роки.
Як керівник зміни він стежить, що викидають люди і в якому обсязі,
бо за деякі види відходів треба ще й доплатити.
Загалом у нас єдиний тариф за один кубічний метр таких відходів - 15 євро.
Це побутове, габаритне і будівельне сміття. Все решта – безкоштовно.
Я провів на станції прийому спецсміття дві години,
і за цей час люди привозили найрізноманітніші відходи.
Навіть цемент, у якого вже давно сплив термін придатності.
Я й сам не знаю, скільки цим колонкам років.
Вони належали ще моєму батькові, вироблені в НДР. Їм вже точно 30-40 років.
Зелені відходи з мого саду. Це тис. Його зрізали і подрібнили.
П'ять величезних мішків зелених відходів зі свого саду
власноруч висипала графиня фон дер Шуленбург, як нам представилася ця жінка.
За день до нас приїздять десь 120-130 людей.
Головна позиція - це будівельне сміття, воно й найважче - це 7-8 тонн на день.
Тоді ще відходи на спалення та габаритне сміття. Тобто загалом десь 10 тонн на день.
Коли контейнери заповнені, їх везуть далі – на відповідний завод із переробки.
Батарейки спочатку сортують вручну - залежно від їхнього складу.
Тоді їх подрібнюють механічним способом.
За допомогою магніту вилучають великі частинки заліза.
Те, що залишилося, повторно подрібнюють.
Далі - гідрометалургійний процес, під час якого нейтралізують електроліт.
На виході отримують солі цинку та марганцю, графіт та метал.
Це все коштовна сировина, яку купують металургійні та інші, приміром, навіть косметичні компанії.
Тож, у царині переробки батарейок у Німеччині велика конкуренція.
Ще один вид спецсміття - автомобільні акумулятори.
Під час їхньої переробки люди працюють у кисневих масках через отруйні випаровування.
Спочатку акумулятори потрапляють в дробарку.
Потім конвеєрною стрічкою суміш з пластику та свинцю, змішана із сірчаною кислотою,
подається до системи вібруючих сит, де суміш розділяють на фракції за щільністю.
Окремо відділяють пластик, свинець розплавляють,
решта металів вспливають на його поверхню, і їх відділяють.
Чистий свинець розливають у форми, і це вже готова сировина,
приміром, для виготовлення нових акумуляторів.
Такий "зондермюль", як розчинники, агресивні фарби та інші небезпечні речовини
відділяють від пластикової упаковки заморожуванням.
Температура у цій системі - мінус сто вісімдесят градусів.
За 10 хвилин заморожена речовина збирається у змішувачах.
Згодом її використовують як додатки під час виготовлення різних видів цементу.
Упаковку переробляють на гранули - це сировина для пластикової промисловості.
За станцією прийому спеціального сміття у Бонні мою увагу привернули будівельні крани.
Друзі, ви тільки погляньте на це грандіозне будівництво.
Тут споруджують не Колізей, не цирк і не стадіон. Тут - прийматимуть сміття.
Легкові автівки і велосипеди заїжджатимуть на верхній рівень,
і люди скидатимуть сміття у контейнери, що стоятимуть на нижньому рівні.
Звідси вантажівки забиратимуть заповнені контейнери.
Таким чином приватний транспорт і вантажІвки не перетинатимуться.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що ще вам цікаво дізнатися про Німеччину,
і я обов'язково покажу це в наступній серії. Побачимося!